so sometimes you got to eat neatly you  know you've got to put on bibs  someone dared us ramen challenge well I  think that we have great team chemistry  then kill this I'm pretty sure I'm gonna  throw up you're not tall enough for this  I don't think you got a good for man not  wrong way upside down those outside huh  very good man okay get some drop ramen  you're gonna get you have to even out  the chopsticks chicken whole lump  say where you are stay away yeah thank  you oh it's fantastic man thank you what  a gentleman is actually points a broth  tip to spoon are you the waterboarding  me or one yeah  I think I did bad Holly I did really  good I mean he had a hard time finding  an egg but I mean he followed the  directions really well the challenge  doesn't account for the fact that I  laugh every like five seconds  it's literally dripping off of here how  we bonded a lot over this well how come  we never got coffee bro